we do indeed we are here with Jennifer
you Jennifer another victory for you
congratulations you never know which
Rita you're going to get the one surging
three victories in a row or the one
that's just like giving pieces like that
how do you prepare for this type of game
I actually wasn't had such a dilemma
yesterday because I didn't know what to
play um against her just also because of
that and I do think she has one of the
strongest repertoires like of the field
um which made it really difficult so I
like ended up playing um the caracon
which
it's a bit of a weird choice because she
already played it twice this tournament
and she like won both of those games
really nicely but
um I just thought like I I felt this is
definitely something she would not
prepare against me for sure so that was
just kind of my goal to not get killed
at the opening and then you know I think
if I got like a nice end game position
um uh I would be really happy which is
what happened and that's exactly what
happened and I think she played E5 in
her previous games right yeah but I
think she used to play Knight C3 like
five Bishop for an H4
and you prepare this night with Knight
to F6 not Bishop to F5 which seems to be
the main line
and uh
what was the critical moment where'd you
feel like you took her out of her
opening
um well I knew like around here I think
Bishop F5 is not the most common move
like she because she started thinking
here after Bishop F5 which I looked at a
little bit but I
um didn't expect Bishop C4
um so I
I think I might not have played the
beginning part of the game really
accurately but after she played the C4
um the Pawns in the center started to
get a little weak and then I hear
after most C4 yeah often C4 um so now it
like it doesn't look so obvious how I
can attack them but I have something
like nice regrouping ideas I can like
um sort of like what happened in game
put my Rook onto the D file and then at
some point maybe go F5 instead of six
which is what I was planning and then
she played this which kind of gave me a
chance here which was nice because
otherwise I was just gonna do
um something like Bishop to C3 let's say
yeah like F5
um three and then
and I was gonna go other than that like
maybe move tonight to be success support
or Bishop F6 but it's just like yeah I
was just gonna be like I felt like it
was gonna be a long maneuvering game and
then I kind of got a chance here so you
felt quite comfortable at this point
yeah I was fine with it um like I you
know I don't think I was worse I thought
I was like I might have been slightly
better even though
um just because the way the position
felt like it was easier for me to play
because I have a Target on D4
[Music]
um
and she played this movie five it
definitely felt off
um and I think right now you're just
winning some material yeah so um before
94 and then
rookie7 I just didn't understand like I
thought Bishop D2 was going to be a try
um because I I still think I'll be
speech six right yeah like I think I'm
better here but um
like I'm up by I saw a pond but you know
you still have some counter play but
after
um this Brook sock I just it's just over
after this one not only that you're
taking the exchange you're also taking
on D4 and breaking through so it's very
puzzling why she did this and after that
I think you just converted uh flawlessly
Jennifer congratulations uh beginning
for you now you're back in the lead it
always changes every single round the
leadership changes yeah why is that I
think it's um this is kind of the nature
of this field like you see it every year
when there's a different person that
wins too it's just there's a lot of
people around like similar strains and
everyone just kind of like depending on
over performs and then performs so it's
just kind of who's you know kind of got
the the street going and then there's
always a little bit luck but it's
definitely not like set in stone
anything
guys any questions for uh Jennifer yeah
of course first of all Jennifer
congratulations uh for getting back into
the lead I want to turn your attention
to this crazy position between Alice Lee
and Arena Crush for a moment
uh have you ever had a game where where
you you you you had uh four pawns for a
rook
because we're about four or three I
think actually
oh you've had three that's pretty good
uh just your quick assessment of this
position because uh the the the panel
here have all taken different who's
better uh positions like I've taken a
draw Anastasia you thought Alice will
win yes and Christians
particular Rook why not so you gotta
break the tie yes I mean I think it is
four versus Rook then I think Alice
might be because it's you know as long
as you don't lose all your pawns you're
not losing well if you lose one then
well three versus Rook is still like
kind of took our chances yeah how did
you break the tie you're with me right
[Music]
with the Pew golly thank you for coming
Jen bye
yeah I hope I should uh